I auditioned for Superman 18 years ago
whenever that it or whatever that
iteration was 15 years ago the one that
um Brandon Routh I don't think so I
think it was before that I think it was
the the sort of one that Nick Cage ended
up almost doing the Kevin Smith one
Tim Burton isn't it oh I don't know I'm
not sure I I didn't make it to the
director stage I barely got on the lot I
auditioned for Anakin Skywalker back in
the origin like the original I remember
them saying to me it's not going to work
because he doesn't have blue eyes and I
was like
creating entire armies full of mutant
robots yeah you can't change somebody's
eyes Rob thanks beautiful eyes you would
have made a great Ewok yeah I would have
made a good Ewok yeah